pop
dans d'énormes usines isolé du monde
entouré d'un réseau de sécurité --dont
bâtiments et terrains couvrez 24 mille
hectares soixante quinze mille personnes
coupée de l'extérieur au pendant des
mois à veiller à la réalisation de la
bombe atomique
après que des savants de toupet 10 us
mise au point les techniques issues des
découvertes françaises sur la
dissociation de l'atome
l'atom est formé d'un noyau composé de
protons et de neutrons autour duquel
tournent des électrons le nombre de ceux
ci détermine la nature du corps un seul
électron et c'est l'hydrogène de
sélénium ouah c'est le lithium
92 c'est l'uranium la possibilité enfin
découverte de diviser l'atome au moyen
d'un neutron permis la naissance de la
bombe atomique
c'est dans les déserts du
nouveau-mexique que lieu de nuit la
première expérience
[Musique]
à près de 10 km voilà ce qu'a enregistré
la caméra le fut mais lumineuse qui
s'élèvent à 13 km de hauteur
la même distance mais d'un autre angle
voici ce que découvrez une autre caméra
vision dantesque et monstrueuse nous
savons maintenant quelles sont les
vraies aspects d'une fin du monde
hiroshima vingt jours après cette
expérience était le premier point de
chute
une seule bombe et passa presque de la
carte
cette ville de 340 mille habitants
trois jours après c'était le tour de
nagasaki sur des kilomètres maintenant
seul tracé des rues témoigne de
l'existence passée d'une ville seuls
quelques bâtisses par est oubliée sur ce
champ de ruines
tout est mort disparu volatilisé
les hommes ont arraché un nouveau secret
comment désormais l'emploi rend-il la
bombe atomique a gagné la guerre la
dissociation l'atome servira-t-elle la
paix
[Musique]